hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts commercializing nano
medicine for improving human health not
just the highest it's really happening
presented by dr. Thomas Webster
professor and department chair of
chemical engineering and art Zafar polo
chair in engineering affiliated faculty
in bioengineering at Northeastern
University College of Engineering I'm
Susie Valdez elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that if you have any
questions please click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions into the
dropped off box box appearing on that
screen and our presenter will address
your questions with answers via email
after the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that help
desk button located on the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use that ask a question box
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation box
button located at the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen and
follow the process for obtaining those
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming dr. Thomas Webster I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir very much for that nice
introduction and the opportunity for me
to present some of the groundbreaking
research we are doing in the area of
nanotechnology so I have about 20 years
of experience looking at how the body
interacts with nanomaterials and what
we're finding out and what you'll hear
in this presentation is that there are
very controlled ways to dictate what the
body
as using nanomaterials and the most
exciting thing that I'll present to you
is that we are able to control body
functions using nano materials without
pharmaceutical agents and I'll describe
why that is such an important objective
for us in this presentation so first of
all the reason why we are focused on
nano materials and not pharmaceutical
agents to combat different disease is
something called the emergence of
antibiotic resistant bacteria while I
think we all know that antibiotic
resistant bacteria is a huge problem we
may not appreciate just how large of a
problem this is going to be in the years
ahead
in fact many different thought agencies
US government agencies as well as
worldwide agencies have recognized the
problem that we will face with
antibiotic resistant bacteria in the
years ahead on this slide you can
clearly see some statistics that places
like the Centers for Disease Control are
reporting this graph that's indicated
here indicates that by the year 2050
more people in fact an estimated 10
million people will actually die from
antibiotic resistant bacteria antibiotic
resistant infections this is alarming
when you consider how this compares to
other diseases that we're used to seeing
such harmful statistics for so also
pictured on the slide is an estimated
number of people that will die from
cancer by 2050 and it's roughly 8.2
million is what the Centers for Disease
Control or the CDC predicts so really
what this statistics should say to us is
that more people are predicted to die
from antibiotic resistant bacterial
infections than all cancers combined by
2050 this is amazing and just
thought-provoking to think about
because if you consider all of the
resources that we have put towards
fighting cancer the amount of money and
I would say the amount of energy that we
have put towards fighting antibiotic
resistant bacteria pales in comparison
now of course we want to reduce cancer
even more than what we're doing today
but we also need to pay attention to
strategies that can reduce the emergence
of antibiotic resistant bacteria
now these statistics should not only be
alarming to us but they should also
highlight that perhaps our approach to
use antibiotics to kill bacteria is not
working and as we know there are many
fields that have emerged in particular
nanotechnology is one that I'm pretty
excited about that we are looking at
fighting bacteria without drugs to keep
these statistics from occurring to keep
the growing number of antibiotic
resistant bacteria from growing which is
affecting the world population so what
I'd like to do in the very beginning
here of the presentation after
highlighting how important it is for us
to fight antibiotic resistant bacteria I
would like to highlight some fundamental
definitions in nanotechnology since the
average person might not know that much
about nanotechnology and quite honestly
it's a relatively new field that is very
broad but yet again very exciting there
are many reasons to look at
nanotechnology to fight bacteria without
drugs one of the first things you can do
is simply look at nature look all around
at living organisms in nature and you
find beautiful very distinct nanoscale
features this is just one of many
examples that I could provide if you
consider a cicada or a locust or any
kind of insect and you look at the wing
of that insect you will find many
distinct nanoscale
features in fact that's what's pictured
in be is a high-resolution microscopy
image of what the wing of an insect
looks like so why is this important this
is important because if you try to grow
bacteria on this insect wing they don't
grow whether it's a grand positive
bacteria a gram-negative bacteria and
antibiotic resistant bacteria you cannot
get them to grow on these kinds of
surfaces so compare that to the kind of
surfaces that we implant on our medical
devices today they don't possess
nanoscale features so the hip implant
that you might have or your grandparent
might have the vascular stent that
somebody might have the catheter that
might have been used to help deliver a
blood transfusion
they don't have nanoscale features on
their surface they are what we call nano
smooth so it begs the question if nature
has evolved to have these very unique
nanoscale features why aren't we using
them in everyday life to reduce bacteria
growth to reduce infection to really
reduce the emergence of antibiotic
resistant bacteria and that's one of the
things we have been focusing on so if
you again consider what this means for a
medical device what this means for
medicine what I haven't included on this
slide these two pictures is what the
surface of an everyday hip implant looks
like and I've labeled that today's
implant as we know in many hip implants
and many orthopedic applications those
micron features that you see in today's
implant actually improves bone growth
unfortunate fortunately initely
have been shown to increase bacterial
growth bacteria are about one micron in
diameter most of them and they can
easily get stuck they can easily situate
in the
larger micron features on today's
implant and contrast what I've also
included on this slide is a nano
structured implant and there are many
ways that you can transform today's
implant into a nano structured implant
but if you have nano scale features on
that implant those features are too
small to allow for that micron featured
bacteria to situate inside that material
so there are many again exciting
opportunities and exciting reasons to
look at nanostructured materials in
medicine they mimic nature and nature
has been able to reduce bacterial growth
on some of these surfaces and they also
have size dimensions that keep these
micron structured microorganisms like
bacteria from attaching to them many
people actually refer to these nano
structures as a bed of nails and these
bed of nails again while they can allow
for tissue to form and they can allow
for larger mammalian cells to attach
they do not allow for nanostructured
micro or micro organisms I should say
like bacteria to attach so while this
argument of biologically inspired
features mimicking the wing of an insect
sounds great we've also been interested
in a more deeper explanation for why
bacteria don't like these surfaces and
I'll show you some of the surfaces that
we've created telling you how we've
created them that reduce bacterial
growth the best I want to talk I want to
talk I'm going to talk about talk about
this why bacteria don't like
nanostructured features whether it's an
insect wing or something we put on an
implant like a catheter or hip implant
and really it has to do with something
called surface energy so every surface
has energy associated with it and what
basically surface energy means is how
hydrophilic or how hydrophobic something
is how
well does a water drop spread on a
surface that's a measure of its energy
when you take a sample an implant a wind
insect wing and you have nanoscale
features on that wing you change energy
of that surface so what I pictured on
this slide would I have diagrams on the
slide on the left in green is a surface
think of any surface that has nanoscale
features it changes in energy quite
simply because you're changing surface
area so if you envision a flat surface
that's made of titanium titanium is one
of the most popular orthopedic implant
chemistry's it will have a certain
surface energy if you then take that
titanium and put these nanoscale
features on there like what's diagrammed
in green you have now increased the
amount of titanium that's exposed that
increased amount of titanium increased
surface area of titanium leads to
different surface energy more exposure
of a hydrophilic chemistry will give you
more hydro Felicity similarly if we
started with a hydrophobic chemistry
like a polymer and that polymer we
consider what its energy is when flat
versus when it has nanoscale features we
quickly can understand that there's more
surface area in that polymer when it has
nanoscale features and that in turn can
lead to more hydrophobic interactions
because you have more hydrophobic
polymer chemistry's exposed so why is
that important that we have changed the
surface energy of a material when
putting nanoscale features on it the
reason why that's important is in our
bodies we have countless proteins that
will initially adsorb to any medical
device any material you put in the body
you'll get immediate adsorption of
proteins every one of those proteins has
due
prynt energy so if you start changing
the energy of your surface you're going
to change what proteins adsorb from your
bodily fluids to that implant that's
been now inserted in you so if you know
that a certain protein promotes bone
growth then figure out what the energy
of that protein is and make your surface
match that energy similarly for bacteria
if you know that mucin which is a
protein in your saliva can reduce
bacteria growth then figure out what the
energy of mucin is make your surface
through nano features match that energy
and then you can increase the absorption
of mucin which will inhibit bacteria
from attaching and again this is all
without antibiotics all without drugs
it's changing the surface to give you
the energy you need to promote the
absorption of proteins that these cells
depend on to attach or not
so what's pictured on the right side of
the slide is that exact point you have a
substrate or an implant you again have
changed that surface energy by putting
nanoscale features on it that can alter
adsorption of a protein one protein that
is excellent at increasing bone growth
and decreasing bacteria attachment is
fibronectin so that's why I included
fibronectin in this diagram and then you
can see a mammalian cell a bone forming
cell that is attaching to that protein
which has absorbed so again the deeper
understanding of why these surfaces
whether it's an insect wing or an
implant that has nano features a deeper
understanding of how they control cell
function is they change in energy which
results in the change of a protein
absorbing and therefore change in cell
attachment and function so we're
engineers in this area you might know
engineers like equations we like to
model thin
we like to predict things so we've
created an equation around this whole
process I believe we're the first group
to actually provide a predictive
equation that will tell you if you give
us a sample our equation will tell you
what size of nano feature should you put
on that implant or that chemistry to
reduce bacteria attachment again without
using a drug or an antibiotic so let me
quickly explain this equation because we
love it when other people use our
equation and you test to see does it
work for your example the more data we
get on our equation the more we can
perfect our equation so our equation
again over here on the left part of the
slide involves three key terms the first
term pictured on the e sub s diagram is
the energy of the protein that you want
to adsorb so again if it's mucin because
mucin reduces bacteria attachment then
the energy of mucin is what you would
put in a sub s the next term e sub 0
comma s is the starting energy of your
material so this is the flat version of
your material on the slide a is a flat
version of a polymer that is used in
many medical devices that polymer is
called poly carbonate urethane when when
we use it as catheters or in other
implant applications today it has no
nano features so that's why in a that
sample looks pretty smooth it's smooth
at the nano scale so then we go back to
our equation we know what e sub s is
that's the energy of the protein we want
to adsorb like mucin we know what V sub
0 comma s is that's the starting surface
energy of polyurethane we can calculate
that using contact angles or many other
scientific methods what we then solve
for
is that our e FF what that means is
effective surface roughness so that
effective surface roughness is expanded
in the equation below and it's written
for the Z height so that letter Z in
there we can calculate it and that tells
us how tall our nano scale feature
should be I could have also written this
in the X direction so X is how wide our
nano feature should be or I could have
written this in the L in the Y Direction
how long should that nano feature be so
we back calculate out using this
equation what's the height the width the
length of that nano scale feature to
give us the energy to adsorb mucin and
that's exactly what's shown on the slide
going from a the smooth polycarbonate
urethane to B which has a little bit
couple more nanoscale features going to
C has a lot more nanoscale features and
then to D which has the most nano scale
features we created nanoscale features
here by putting carbon nanotubes
underneath the polymer carbon nanotubes
are nanoscale orientations of carbon and
that provides this type of roughness the
more we add the more roughness we get
and that's what's shown in the graph on
e basically going from zero weight
percent carbon nanotubes and
polyurethane which is the letter A 213
weight percent which is letter B 220
weight percent which is letter C and
then 233 weight percent is letter D so
of course we see an increase of
roughness the more carbon nanotubes we
add if you then look at the graph and F
that shows you the change of contact
angle or the change of energy you're
getting when you increase nanoscale
features so simply going from again 0 to
33 weight percent carbon nanotubes going
from the image and a to the image and D
we get a more hydrophilic surface that
water drop is spreading more
when we have more nanoscale features we
stopped at 33% and you might ask why why
did we stop at the nanoscale roughness
we got when we added thirty-three weight
percent of carbon nanotubes to
polycarbonate urethane the reason is the
energy we got as you can see in the
graph again on F the energy we got when
using 33 weight percent is the same
energy as mucin so it gave us the same
energy to enhance the absorption of a
protein mucin that reduces bacteria
attachment so and that's what's shown in
G it basically is a analyzer test if
you're familiar with that to measure how
much of a protein is absorbing to our
surface and we get the most mucin
absorbing when we use 33 weight percent
carbon nanotubes so again what I want to
highlight in this presentation is this
idea of the getting of material off the
shelf
adding nanoscale features and again
we'll talk about other ways you can do
this
but adding those nanoscale features to
give you the energy to adsorb a protein
that will then reduce infection or
reduce bacteria attachment I also want
to add that we have taken this idea to
the FDA and the FDA has approved our
materials which increase in the Anno
scale roughness for medical applications
many people often wonder where is the
FDA in terms of thinking about
nanotechnology and nano medicine and I'm
here to tell you there are a number of
materials that have nano scale features
that have been approved by the FDA for
implantation and the reason it's
occurred so quickly is because we're not
changing chemistry we're changing
roughness if you introduce a new
chemistry to the body your regulatory
approval is going to be much longer if
you simply take existing chemistry's
that are approved by the FDA and put an
atom scale features on them you can have
a much quicker path to
FDA approval so some of these materials
that I'm going to talk about in part one
of my presentation are materials that
have been approved by the FDA for
implantation and they use nanotechnology
and nano structured features so if you
ever hear somebody say that there's no
real value that has come out of
nanotechnology and medicine they're
wrong because there are a number of
materials that have been approved
they're implanted in humans today that
use nano materials and they're showing
decreased infection as we're talking
about without drugs so let me give you
some of those examples
now one of the first materials we
studied and this was probably about six
years ago was a material called silicon
nitride it's a ceramic it's
commercialized by a company called
America and it essentially is pictured
here in the upper right and I call it
smooth silicon nitride because at this
scale bar of a scanning electron
micrograph we don't see a lot of
nanoscale features you do see some
grooved lines and some micron topography
but certainly there's not a lot of Nano
topography so we wanted to reduce
infection of this chemistry so we
followed our equation again we plugged
in what's the starting surface energy of
the silicon nitride sample
what's the protein we want to adsorb
that can both increase bone funk bone
growth and decrease bacterial growth we
calculated out the Z height the x width
the Y length and the the Nano rough
silicon nitride the image here in the
upper left is what we've got so this is
the exact dimensions of nanoscale
features that our equation told us we
should create to reduce infection we
also compared this to titanium titanium
of course as I mentioned is a widely
popular material in orthopaedics and we
also compared it to a polymer called
Peak or poly ether ether ketone poly
ether ether
is the number one implanted spinal
implant material so it is great
mechanical properties it has a really
nice behavior for mechanical situations
in the spine unfortunately there's a lot
of infection that occurs for peek
because it is not of you know it does
not resist bacterial growth so let me
show you what we did we communicated
with the FDA what kind of study should
we do to look at infection of these
materials and we got feedback that if we
put bacteria on these samples ahead of
time and then implanted the samples with
bacteria into what's called the calvaria
of skulls that would be a great
infection model so we used rats in this
study again each of these micro grafts
are histology stains in which we had the
MIT the implant with bacteria on it and
inserted that into the skulls of rats on
all four of these images if you see
yellow that means an infection that's a
stain for bacteria and biofilm producing
bacteria we also have a stain for bone
growth and that's purple so if we look
at the worst material again peak that I
mentioned in the lower left corner of
this slide there was a ton of infection
so the bacteria that we initially seeded
grew very fast they produced a lot of
infection that infection kept bone from
growing as you might imagine in fact if
you have a bacteria in bone it becomes a
really bad clinical situation where you
have to drill out you have to remove the
implant and you have to drill out the
bone that has the bacteria because right
now there's no way to just kill that
bacteria and leave the rest of the bone
present so we've quantified this you can
see for peak ninety-five percent of the
surface was covered with bacteria after
three month
titanium which is pictured just above
peak did a little bit better but you can
still see a lot of yellow particularly
on the right side of this particular
slide so that yellow again signs of
bacteria when we quantified it we got on
average 67 percent of the titanium
surface was covered in bacteria when we
moved to silicon nitride changing
chemistry already improved our ability
to inhibit bacteria so on the the bottom
right corner you can see silicon nitride
that's smooth so this was the starting
material made by a medica immediately
there was a reduction in bacterial
growth so there's something unique about
the silicon nitride chemistry the
silicon nitride surface energy that
reduces bacteria attachment and growth
but still we saw 10% of the surface of
silicon nitride of the smooth silicon
nitride covered with bacteria so ten
percent is still pretty large amount in
fact you can see there's gaps in bone
growth surrounding that implant so those
gaps in purple color the white color are
regions of no GaN growth and that's
because there was bacteria that was
present in those locations so there's
still reason for improvement for that
smooth silicon nitride so then you look
at the best material and that was the
silicon nitride that had the nanoscale
features the Nano rough silicon nitride
and again no antibiotics were used in
the study these are simply the same
chemistry silicon nitride that had those
nanoscale features we ended up with zero
no bacteria present on that surface
after three months that of course
allowed for a lot more bone growth in
fact the most bone growth out of these
four samples and it was at about 41
percent of that surface of silicon
nitride was covered with bone let me
give you another example
people so now instead of silicon nitride
think of titanium and how we can improve
upon titanium and reduce the infection
of titanium based orthopedic implants
another way you can create nanoscale
features is by a process called
anodization and that's what's diagrammed
on this slide anodization is a real
simple well understood process where you
put titanium serves as the anode into an
electrolyte solution we use HF or
hydrofluoric acid you apply a voltage
where a certain period of time as
indicated on this slide and you can
create nanoscale features on bone pins
so this slide shows you a low
magnification image of this anodized
bone pin and a high magnification
picture showing nanoscale features of
this bone pen again bone pins are used
all the time in orthopedics for various
bone fractures in this study we were
very interested in creating a better
device for an amputee and an amputee is
one of the most difficult orthopaedic
situations to find solutions for as you
might realize whenever you lose part of
your limb there are several strategies
to try to return function to that limb
one is simply to fit a plastic
prosthetic or the remaining limb around
what's left or in this case a much
better strategy is what's called an
Osseo integrated limb this is where you
take the screw you put it into the
remaining part of the limb and then you
fit a plastic prosthetic around the
screw this is to increase stability and
to decrease abrasion and friction that
is felt if you don't use a bone pin and
you just put that plastic prosthetic
around the remaining limb so nonetheless
we took some pins that again are
inserted into the remaining limb of a
the mole model we have for an amputee
some of those pins were anodized to have
these nanoscale features that you can
see on this slide some of them were not
anodized so they were nano smooth
features we of course followed our
equation as I mentioned before to tell
us what size nanoscale features should
we put on the pin to give us the energy
to adsorb proteins necessary to reduce
infection for these devices here's an
x-ray of our of our amputee rat model
and again you can see the femur right
here that still exists inside of the rat
and the amputee model resected the rest
of the limb and there's that bone pin
that goes right into the remaining limb
so again the reason why this is so
complicated for orthopedic surgeons for
people developing improved biomaterials
you have a metal that's sticking out of
the body that this prosthetic will fit
on so that metal has to bond to bone it
has to all CU integrate but it also has
to bond to soft tissue and skin because
you need the wound to close around the
screw to keep bacteria out to minimize
inflammation and just to highlight how
important of a problem this is there was
a recent study survey that was done by
the Department of Defense in the United
States this survey found that more
people were unhappy with their
prosthetic if they were an amputee they
were more unhappy with their prosthetic
than if they received no prosthetic at
all so in other words as as orthopedic
surgeons as biomaterial specialists we
try to create a better limb remaining
limb for amputees but the data is
showing the survey is showing that our
soldiers were much more disappointed
with receiving these kinds of surgeries
and if we did nothing at all so that
really highlights this problem we have
with amputee biomaterials
so the results from this study we're
incredibly promising I don't have a
movie here to show you but I do have the
rat qualitatively you can you can see
where the screw is in the back right leg
of this rat and what we saw was the rat
was walking on the anodised the Nano
textured titanium implant three days
after surgery for the control pin the
one that's used today this rat did not
walk on it for 28 days so and that's as
far as we took this study was for 28
days
so clearly the rat felt more comfortable
with this anodized implant than
unanalyzed
or nano smooth implant when we look at
the wound the exit wound
where the metal is coming out of the rat
again the spot that the prosthetic would
fit on it's clear to see why the
nanostructured implant did so much
better this first row of images is the
pin that's used today you can see an
open wound after 14 days 21 days 28 days
that red tissue that you see is inflamed
tissue it got infected there were signs
of bacteria on the screw crawling into
the femur into the rat so it was a clear
problem when not having nanoscale
features the middle row and the bottom
row are two examples of Nano textured
surfaces one was that nano tubular
surface geometry that we created using
anodization if we change the process a
little bit we get what's called nano
rough not nanotubes but just hemispheres
of nanoscale features either type of
nanoscale feature we created you can see
the wound closed so the skin grew onto
the screw after 14 21 and 28 days this
again kept bacteria out it reduced
inflammation and it allowed the pin to
grow into bone so again no
antibiotics were used this is simply
putting nano texturing on these devices
which helped reduce bacterial growth
allowed for skin to grow allowed for
bone to grow and allowed for a
successful material so this one is also
approved by the FDA the silicon nitride
example I did not mention this at the
time but that has also been approved the
Nano textured version by the FDA for
orthopedic applications so here's two
examples of nano texturing that has
reduced infection and has been approved
by the FDA for implantation let me give
you a last example of a nano textured
surface before moving into the next part
of my talk so you might wonder ok this
approach of nano texturing seems to work
on metals which is what titanium is it
worked on silicon nitride which is a
ceramic so how about polymers can you
create polymers to have nano textures to
reduce bacterial infection without using
an antibiotic and you know of course I'm
going to say the answer is yes and you
can see here the third example that I'll
give us for catheters or endotracheal
tubes these are polymeric materials
clearly and again our objective here was
to create Nano textures on the inside of
these catheters or endotracheal tubes to
reduce infection this is also a very big
problem in medicine if you have a
catheter for a long period of time of
course the chances of getting infection
go higher and higher and many times the
clinician does not know you have an
infection until they see bacteria in
your blood a systemic infection and this
clearly then allows the bacteria to go
everywhere in your body so we need a
much better approach to keep bacteria
from growing on these catheters these
endotracheal tubes to reduce systemic
infections so our process that we
followed to create nano structured
features on these polymers was
very straightforward catheters are very
inexpensive so in order for this to be
adaptable to the clinical community we
needed a very inexpensive process to
create nanoscale features catheters are
you know one dollar or two dollars so
you cannot propose something very
sophisticated that would cost thousands
of dollars to create nanoscale features
on catheters and expect them to be
adopted by the industry so we used a
cast mold technique very cheap very
simple and again our material we used to
copy roughness onto the polymer was our
anodized titanium the same material that
I just discussed for that amputee model
we followed it anodization process we
were able to generate nanoscale features
similar to what I showed you before
here's a picture in the upper right of
these unique nanoscale features we
create on titanium that roughness can
then be copied over to a polymer by
simply pouring a mold making a mold of
this titanium and then pouring polymer
but PDMS which is polydimethylsiloxane
into that mold and you can copy over the
roughness just like any kind of cast
mold process that's used in many
different industries and here you see in
a is the starting titanium the nano
smooth titanium the picture right below
it is a PDMS copy of that starting
titanium so both are very smooth at the
nanoscale if you then look at B again
that's our anodized titanium has all
those nice anodized nanotubes and our
PDMS copy of that titanium is in Picher
d so we were able to copy the roughness
over to the polymer again we followed
our equation what size of features do we
need to get the energy to allow for
proteins to adsorb to this catheter that
would reduce an infection we measured
wettability
remember our goal is to transform that
surface energy to one that would promote
protein absorption so here you can see
an a are starting PDMS so this is the
catheter you would find today on the
market and then in B as a nano textured
one clearly you see a different
spreading of that contact angle again
proving you can change wettability you
can change surface energy by simply
employing nano textured features we also
wanted to check chemistry so without
going into too much detail we used XPS
x-ray photoelectron spectroscopy we saw
the same exact chemistry between the
starting PDMS and the PDMS that had
nanoscale features this again important
for the FDA to show similar chemistry
just changes in nano scale feature
bacteria results showed exactly what we
expected so here is for Staphylococcus
aureus a bacteria that commonly infects
catheters in fact you might be aware of
MRSA which is the antibiotic resistant
version of this bacterium and you can
see after 24 hours 48 hours the density
of bacteria or the colony forming units
per ml significantly lower when we
simply put nanoscale features on those
implants nanoscale features resembling
those that are on the insect wing that I
presented in the beginning just to
highlight the mechanism in case I
haven't been clear about this but here
we also noticed that there was another
protein involved not just mucin which
can really help reduce infection on
orthopedic implants or dental implants
but there's another protein called
Castine that you have in your body and
again you look up that energy create
these catheter surfaces to have
nanoscale features to match the
absorption of caffeine and that's why
we're reducing bacterial growth so the
mechanism of action you need
wettability increased protein absorption
like caffeine caffeine inhibits
bacterial attachment and growth so
that's the the mechanism we believe
occurred so let me switch a little bit
into another part of nanotechnology that
has been receiving a lot of attention in
the literature in the medical community
again the first part was all about nano
texturing of implants and there are many
many examples I could have probably
spent two days talking about other
implants that have nano textured
features that are approved by the FDA
and are now in humans and they're
showing improved tissue growth reduced
infection in some cases reduced scar
tissue formation all of those things
showing much promise that without drugs
you can control cell behavior using nano
textures another area though is
nanoparticles nanoparticles have been a
little bit harder to implement in
medicine and get FDA approval and
there's many reasons why but let me let
me talk about the pros and the cons of
nanoparticles many people are excited
about nanoparticles because they are now
very small and they can get inside of
cells they can get inside of tissue
forming cells they can get inside of
bacteria and they can actually turn on
and off individual parts of cells so you
could create a nanoparticle to go into a
bone cell nucleus and get involved in
DNA attached to it disrupted you can
have nanoparticles go into cancer cells
and begin to heat up under controlled
infrared excitation and that heat that
they generate could kill the cancer cell
so you can use nanoparticles to probe
parts of the body that were once
unthinkable with micron particles so
that's the promise and I'll show you
some examples of how we're using
nanoparticles for bacteria but the
weakness or
problem of nanoparticles is the same
thing as its advantage if you can now
have nanoparticles penetrate your skin
pass through the blood-brain barrier go
into cells you could potentially have
increased toxicity from these particles
because they can go in places that
micron particles were once unable to so
you have to be very very careful and the
FDA is right on top of this asking for a
lot of studies if you're proposing a
nanoparticle to treat a particular
disease but here you can see again a
diagram of a cell you could think of
this as a cancer cell or even a bacteria
where another great advantage of using
nanoparticles is through their small
size and increased surface area you can
now generate more of what's called
reactive oxygen species then you can
with a larger micron particle right
envision a box and that box has micron
particles for one box for another box it
has nanoparticles same volume the
nanoparticles have much more surface
area which means if they produce
reactive oxygen species they can produce
a lot more reactive oxygen species
because they have more surface area
reactive oxygen species as you might
know can kill bacteria so it's a very
common way to kill bacteria many drugs
are involved in reactive oxygen species
but we have seen without drugs
nanoparticles can result in the
generation of reactive oxygen species to
kill those bacteria so there's a lot of
advances going on with silver
nanoparticles that generate reactive
oxygen species things like seria oxide
that is a great modulator of reactive
oxygen species so there's a lot of
really fascinating nanoparticles that
now can be used to kill
tyria that before we wouldn't even think
of using those kinds of chemistry's so
here's an example of another fascinating
advancement in using nanoparticles in
medicine so many times when you have an
infection you might be going through
cancer treatment in fact infection rates
for cancer treatments are incredibly
high and that's clearly because patients
are going through chemotherapy they have
weakened immune systems which make them
more susceptible to bacteria and
infections while we are creating and
other people in the field are - what we
call synthetic immune nanoparticles so
it's a boost to your immune system these
nanoparticles you can see dozens of them
in the picture on the Left there's about
four or five of them on the picture on
the right the higher magnification we
functionalize these synthetic
nanoparticles to attack bacteria so we
know certain receptors on the bacteria
we put those complementary attachment
regions to our nanoparticles so that our
nanoparticles attack that bacteria this
bacteria on these slides are ecoli ecoli
clearly isn't a lot of food and can
cause problems for people if ecoli gets
inside of you so what these particles do
is they first attach to the cell
membrane we have seen many nanoparticles
can kill bacteria simply by attaching to
their membrane because they clog the
membrane they keep nutrients from going
in because they've clogged the membrane
and they keep waste from coming out
again because they've clogged the
membrane so clogging the membrane with a
nanoparticle is a great way to kill a
bacteria without a drug but moreover
some of these particles and you can see
this in the right image can actually go
into the bacteria so one of these
particles has silver nanoparticles
inside of it and it passes the cell
membrane and then can release
of these other nanoparticles to generate
reactive oxygen species to then kill the
bacteria so the other value in this
synthetic immune nanoparticle is we can
also use it as a detecting source so can
it tell us that that bacteria is present
in your body not only kill it if it's
there but tell you if it's there and we
are creating these nanoparticles to be
sensors in your body and how this works
is if you if you look at this picture on
the left with a dozen of dozens of
nanoparticles surrounding the bacteria
once they do that if you have a
conductive material inside the
nanoparticle then it increases the
conductivity in that region which you
can detect using some kind of imaging
modality so because you've put a
conductive material in there or maybe in
some of our studies we put iron in there
once they congregate around a bacteria
you can image that and you can determine
that in fact you do have ecoli or some
other bacteria that's present so we're
pioneering this field that's called
bacteria theranostics which theranostics
means same material does the therapy and
same material does the Diagnostics in
contrast today where we have one process
that does the Diagnostics and one
process that does the therapy we're
creating things like these synthetic
immune nanoparticles to do both at once
so speaking of iron oxide there's also
approaches you can use nanoparticles to
kill bacteria after a biofilm has formed
so once bacteria attached to a surface
or a tissue
in your body if they grow to confluence
if they cover the surface and then they
form multi layers they'll eventually
form what's called a biofilm biofilm is
kind of this mucus sticky substance that
is impenetrable to antibiotics so
it's kind of a shell around the bacteria
that creates a little micro environment
that keeps antibiotics from going in and
this is why
antibiotics have been useless in
fighting bacteria once you have a
biofilm that forms well although the
antibiotics cannot penetrate the biofilm
nanoparticles can and in one particular
area of study that we have we're using
iron oxide nanoparticles or some people
call them polymers ohms which are
magnetic irons a magnetic chemistry so
you can basically use magnetic power
magnetic force to get those
nanoparticles to go through the biofilm
then go into the bacteria disrupt the
biofilm kill the bacteria where at one
point you couldn't treat it you now can
with antibiotics I mean with iron oxide
nanoparticles antibiotics were not
effective so here's a picture of some of
those collection of iron oxide
nanoparticles below you can see a
solution of them but again what makes
them beautiful is they're magnetic so
once they're in the body you can control
where they go so if you have an
infection in a remote hard-to-get-to
location in your small intestine you
could inject a patient with these iron
oxide nanoparticles use a magnetic force
to drive those particles to that
infection determine if you have an
infection because again you can image
these iron oxide nanoparticles and then
in real time you can watch is that
infection
reducing is it ineffective your
treatment and you need another injection
of iron oxide nanoparticles you can
watch the treatment occur while you're
in the hospital or in that doctors suite
here's a quick experiment to show you
how well a magnet does in terms of these
iron oxide nanoparticles these two
images are the same field of view one is
a bright field image where you can see
the dark black area is a magnet
so we put a magnet underneath the petri
dish we add all these bacteria grow a
biofilm and you can see you know in the
bright field image where that magnet is
situated again the same image just under
florescent mode is on the right and this
is what's called a live dead stain so we
apply our magnetic nanoparticles and
then we stain four green means that the
bacteria are living red means the
bacteria are dead so you can see right
where we place the magnet that's drawing
the iron oxide nanoparticles into the
biofilm into the bacteria and it's
killing them where we don't have the
magnet we're still seeing live bacteria
so again proof of principle that you can
use a magnet to drive these
nanoparticles inside a biofilm to kill
bacteria
another chemistry that is getting a lot
of attention today is called selenium
selenium is part of our diet you find it
in many foods in fact where this
interest in selenium came from is there
have been studies to correlate if you do
not have the daily recommended
nutritional value of selenium in your
diet you're more likely to get cancer
then if you have the nutritional diet of
selenium so there's a thought that
selenium might be involved in
anti-cancer properties in fact there are
now containers of selenium vitamins of
selenium that you can purchase well
there's many similarities between
killing cancer and killing bacteria so
we've been very interested in taking
that wonderful information on how
selenium is being used to kill cancer
cells kill tumors and kill bacteria and
just to make a long story short selenium
is often proposed to kill cancer cells
and bacteria as we have shown since it
interferes with bacteria that are
proteins that are inside bacteria so as
soon as selenium crosses the membrane
it dissolves the selenium ions interfere
with some proteins in bacteria and
disrupt their function which results in
death of the bacteria same thing for a
cancer cell the selenium gets inside the
cancer cell interferes with some
bacteria with some proteins that are in
cancer cells and that kills the cancer
cell so we were one of the first groups
to develop a chemical reaction that can
coat almost anything with selenium
nanoparticles so we're doing in the body
applications outside the body
applications bacteria are everywhere so
we're coding a lot of surfaces with
selenium this slide shows you how we
took an uncoated paper towel and B and
coated it with selenium nanoparticles so
all of those little white dots in a our
selenium nanoparticles it's a simple
chemical reaction we actually have a
spray we can spray computer screens door
knobs you name it we can spray this
selenium nanoparticles and they stick to
these surfaces so when doing so we're
seeing great decrease in bacterial
attachment decrease in bacterial growth
here's just some of the raw data where
this is for again Staphylococcus aureus
but we've seen this for many bacteria
where you see significantly reduced v
log reduction in bacterial growth after
24 hours 48 hours 72 hours when coding
these paper towels with selenium so it
might sound trivial but paper towels are
a source of bacterial contamination
think of a hospital in the hospital you
wash your hands after you know you're in
the restroom and you throw away the
paper towel while there is now bacteria
on that paper towel in the trashcan in
the hospital that's a source of
bacterial contamination that if not
treated appropriately could end up
affecting health of people so what we
propose to do is to treat paper towels
with selenium Nano
particles of selenium to really keep
bacteria from growing on these paper
towels or on other materials that might
be in the hospital or everyday life
setting we've also been able to coat
metals stainless steel ultra high
molecular weight polyethylene you can
see on this slide going from the left to
the right
uncoated versions of these metals and
polymers low dose of selenium you start
seeing a couple of white dots medium
dose high dose see more whites I guess
again again again very surfaces and
they're effective at reducing bacterial
attachment we've also seen them
effective at reducing virus attachment
so things like zika ebola the flu virus
these selenium nanoparticles can keep
those entities from absorbing which
again would reduce transmission from
touch to touch on these surfaces here's
a great picture that describes it all -
we've done this for polyvinyl chloride
PVC is a common polymer used for
catheters you can see on the uncoated
polyvinyl chloride catheter millions of
bacteria and these are Staphylococcus
aureus again have attached to this PVC a
simple coating of selenium on there
significantly reduces bacteria
attachment and growth and again this is
not using an antibiotic so that moves me
to the last part of my presentation
which is again of a very active area of
research in the nanotechnology space so
we talked about nano texturing and a
particles
this is self-assembled nanomaterials
these are injectables you would inject
these into the body where you think you
might have an infection or you apply
them onto the surface of skin in which
you think you might have bacterial
presence then these materials assemble
in a controllable way to selectively
kill bacteria so this is the field of
self
assembled nanomaterials which is growing
and growing in popularity because it's
sort of like a pre-programmed nano
material you know it will self assemble
into a controllable way to kill bacteria
our version of self assembled materials
we're using to fight bacteria are called
antimicrobial peptides so what we do is
we simply take things like hydrophobic
amino acids that can attach to the
membrane of a bacteria we then add a
group that's hydrophobic add a group
that's hydrophilic so that it will self
assemble into a rod to then interject
into the bacterial membrane kind of stab
the bacterial membrane and cause the
inside to come out what is nice about
these self-assembled antimicrobial
peptides is they are very strong
interaction with a bacterial cell
membrane as you can see on the left but
they have a weak interaction with
mammalian cell membranes and really the
reason for that is mammalian cells which
we don't want to kill have things like
cholesterol they have other proteins
that are present in the cell wall which
won't be stabbed or won't be influenced
by these self-assembled chemistry's so
they're really selective towards killing
bacteria which is very very important so
here's a visual description of what
these these molecules do again we design
them to self-assemble into rods they
come in close contact with the bacterial
membrane that's pictured here and then
they start going into the bacterial
membrane once they go through part of it
goes through the bacterial membrane part
of it is inside the cell that generates
a whole and from that whole everything
from inside the bacteria comes out and
it dies so these structures the ability
of these self-assembled materials to
assemble into these fibers nanofibers is
very important
because you need something long enough
to go through the membrane and you need
something small enough that it doesn't
come out the other end but it goes right
into that that cell body a bacterial
body here's the specifics of a molecule
that one of the molecules of many that
we're studying and again we need a
hydrophobic tail group we need a beta
sheet forming domain a charge domain and
then a functional domain the hydrocarbon
tail group helps with self-assembly and
a fiber like formation the beta sheet
also helps in that self-assembly and the
functional domain is what allows us to
target ecoli or Staphylococcus aureus or
Pseudomonas aeruginosa so we can use
that red region to target a specific
bacteria so again the picture of how
this happens we create monomers of these
cationic self-assemble peptides they
self assemble into cylindrical
nanoparticles or rods they first attach
to the cell membrane but then because of
their charge they go in to the cell
creating a hole creating this leakage of
the cytoplasm which results in their
death but please keep in mind the same
thing does not happen for the mammalian
cells because of the inability of these
particles these fibers to get through a
mammalian cell membrane so again a
diagram of this specific chemistry we're
looking at if you're interested in that
the hydrocarbon group this beta forming
sheet and then the functional group
there in orange and and how it looks you
know if we diagram this in terms of the
chemical structure so what I want to
highlight is just a real quick study
that we did with these molecules in
which we we highlighted the reason why
they need to form nano structures so
nanotechnology is all about the
importance of the nano size scale so
what we have done is a series of studies
that show how important it is that these
assemble into a nano fiber as compared
to a micron fiber or a nano sphere the
Nano fiber is very very important so we
created our material step by step and we
added it to bacteria so the first step
was just this by card in peptide this
orange region as I mentioned before is
the peptide that targets the cell
membrane the bacterial cell membrane so
we use that as one material another
material we used we call CV kPa this is
really the beta sheet self-assembly part
so we added that just to the peptide
that was our second material our third
material is the whole entire thing so we
now have the hydrocarbon backbone the
beta sheet formation and that region
that attaches to the bacterial membrane
and as you'll see it's all three of
these together the AC a PA that works if
you remove any part of that this three
component system if you remove any part
the whole thing doesn't work and it
doesn't kill bacteria
we of course determined the critical
micelle concentration so this is the
critical concentration at which each of
these components would kill bacteria and
you can see just the by Cardon just the
peptide that attaches to the membrane
doesn't kill bacteria at all under the
critical micelle concentration
there's na not applicable it doesn't
kill it the self-assembly region with
the beta sheet formation and the by
Cardon and the hydrophobic backbone had
a critical micelle concentration of
around 50 which means that's the amount
necessary to kill the bacteria here's
what these structures look like again
you can see these nano fiber formations
of course if you increase the
concentration of these self-assembled
materials you'll get longer and longer
chains so we need to have the right
concentration that will penetrate that
bacterial wall we
confirmed secondary structure to show
that each one of these three materials
is the structure we think it is and most
importantly what I want to share with
you is the ability of these materials to
reduce bacterial growth so we looked at
gram positive bacteria MRSA you can see
with time we're able to inhibit
bacterial growth with gram negative
bacteria this is MDR ecoli or multi
drug-resistant ecoli we completely
eliminated using these self-assembled
molecules live dead stains similar to
what I described before green means
alive red means dead for MRSA the you
know horrible drug resistant
Staphylococcus aureus this
self-assembled molecule almost
completely inhibited MRSA growth multi
drug-resistant coli again you can see
high efficacy at killing those bacteria
but here's the part that I mentioned
before you need each part of this
self-assembled molecule to work so on
this slide are the building blocks by
themselves not the collective molecule
but just each building block the by card
in peptide the peptide AMPA phil they
don't work the y-axis here is the number
of colony forming units it's the same no
matter what concentration you use so
only when you have the combination of
the beta forming sheets the by card in
peptide and the hydrophobic backbone do
you get that fiber to then kill the
bacteria so that's a real definition of
nanotechnology has to form a nano
structure we've also looked at the
mechanism of action for those of you
that are interested in bacterial
lipopolysaccharides our major component
of the membrane of gram-negative
bacteria and you can see here the red is
our self-assembled molecule that is what
attaches the most to that LPS region of
the bacterial membrane if we just had
the building blocks which are in black
and blue we don't get a lot of
attachment
and this last slide before I summarize
is so important because it really shows
you what's happening to the bacteria so
the the nanorods that we created you can
see when we expose them to MRSA or
e.coli the membrane is getting disrupted
and the cell is basically internal
components are coming out of the
bacteria so it's clearly dying as soon
as we disrupt that cell membrane whereas
the controls you see the cell membrane
is intact so the I guess the very last
thing that I'll show here is
cytotoxicity so what important part is
we have identified a concentration at
which these self-assembled materials
work for bacteria but they do not work
and and they do not kill a human dermal
fibroblasts or healthy cells that we
don't want to kill so they are selective
towards bacteria and we can charge them
if you charge these self-assembled
materials they'll coat surfaces so tying
this back into the beginning of my
presentation you can actually use these
on medical devices coat them on medical
devices by inducing a charge and that
will help contact kill bacteria so I
hope I shared with you a couple of
future directions current directions in
nanotechnology I showed you some current
fda-approved processes that we call nano
texturing or nano structured surfaces
which are eliminating infection without
using antibiotics I also provided you a
couple of examples of nanoparticles a
little more risky a little more work
involved in determining bio distribution
and other things and I let I ended the
presentation with a really futuristic
direction of self-assembled
nanomaterials where you can now have a
chemistry that can poke and prod and
disrupt a bacterial membrane to cause it
to die all three of these areas are
really really exciting intersections
between nanotechnology and eliminating
bacterial growth without resorting
drugs but let me leave you with one
final thought and that final thought is
in all of these approaches most likely
you would still have to determine if
someone has bacteria in them and then
give them a solution I gave you a small
example of an immune cell sensor that
we're developing
here's another sensor that we're
developing and the purpose of these
sensors which I'm convinced will be the
future of medicine the promise of these
sensors is that they in fact can
determine if bacteria are present
surrounding your implant and then if so
kill them we don't have that technology
now we don't know in real time if this
is occurring after you get an implant so
quickly what we're doing is we're taking
a hip implant we're growing carbon
nanotubes that's what's pictured in the
bottom right off of the surface carbon
nanotubes can measure the resistance and
therefore determine if a bacteria is
attaching to the implant bacteria have a
different resistance than bone which is
different than scar tissue so we can
identify if bacteria are on your implant
in real time that information is then
sent to a computer or your iPhone to
tell you that you have bacteria
surrounding some of your implant we've
already made an appointment for you with
your doctor so it is an intelligent
system that communicates and talks to
you about what's happening inside your
body the third part to the sensor is
that we developed a polymer that can
release a nano particle or a
self-assembled material on demand and it
does so because it's a conductive
polymer that we apply an electromagnetic
field it will degrade and release
whatever's inside of it so we now have
the ability to determine is a bacteria
present communicate to a handheld device
to your clinician yes it is present and
then thirdly release something
nanoparticles self-assembled material to
kill the bacteria if it's present this
is a true intelligence
and material that has to be the future
of our research in medicine so I'd like
to thank you for paying attention here
are some acknowledgments for funding
sources of course that have occurred
throughout throughout my career which
has enabled us to to do this and of
course my lab group has enabled me to do
all this research I encourage you go to
our website learn more about the things
we're doing nanotechnology and nano
medicine is a fascinating area of
research that I hope more people get
involved in thank you